we didn't have to talk about that
another thing happened this weekend I
know we think the only thing that
happened was the looting and the
pillaging and the mayhem another thing
that happened is a private company shot
a spaceship into space and sent American
astronauts up into space for the first
time in a pretty long time this was Elon
Musk
this was SpaceX and President Trump gave
a speech another powerful speech
powerful in a different way at that
launch an amazing honor you know four
years ago this place was essentially
shut down space core program was over
the shuttle program was dead one of the
Secret Service men said they were here
with the past administration I won't
tell you who and they were here to shut
down the facility and now we're the
leader in the world again and this is
just the beginning they're going to Mars
you go to the moon but they go to the
moon in order to go to Mars it's a
platform Jim would you say that's a
correct statement that's right Jim I
want to congratulate you I want to
congratulate the vice president first
time in a long time and we're going to
Mars
all right we're going yeah we're gonna
go to the moon first and then we're
gonna go Mars we're gonna look upward
those those are the two ways you can
either look down at the rubble look down
at the lies look down at the rancor and
division look inward only it's yourself
and me me me me me or you can look
upward toward the heavens toward what's
next
toward what is to come toward what
happens when we come together band
together and do something that is
productive that is outward looking that
is lovely
that is awe-inspiring that is the
opposite of everything else that we were
told to focus on this past weekend those
are - those are the two choices that are
being offered all right you've got the
left defending the burning down of our
cities and you've got President Trump
walking out the front door of the White
House leading people to a church that
people tried to burn down and holding up
the Bible walking to that platform at
the launch of a spaceship that's going
to go right out to outer space and
saying this is only the beginning those
are two
choices and elections are about choices
as Barack Obama reminds us all of these
stories that we're seeing in the news
are about that election that's coming up
in November and and look beyond that
election which country do you want to
have the choice is ours in
representative Republic such as our
country the representatives represent us
what is it do we want to keep going down
this path of destruction or do we want
to say enough is enough and take another
course
[Music]
you
[Music]